vous n'êtes pas bien préparé les
vêtements nivalle à aurelio tu peux
m'aider à les voilà c'est quoi c'est ça
les gars pompiers le pied
c'est normal vous êtes engueuler elle
allait pas bien je sais pas moi
[Musique]
qui elle est
les séparer en fait enfin
ça va mais oui juste je m'organisais des
enfants
[Musique]
c'est un peu compliqué en son temps ok
je suis pas beaucoup de temps t'es pas
là je suis là a raconté que l'avion
était là on était ensemble je dirais tu
sais arros maman est partie on sait pas
c'est pas pourquoi on sait pas quand
elle va revenir on sait qu'on sait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est les mains du magicien c'est pour
dans quelques segments et sa taille des
graines de traiter d'autres faits parce
que le trèfle à quatre feuilles après
qui peut faire des voeux la même mais
carrément
[Musique]
pour part non plus n'a pas vu grandir
cet enfant tu te laisses moi j'étais là
mais j'avais envie de me parler
[Musique]